hello everyone and welcome to another
exciting match from the Julius bird
generation cup and even though it's
called The Generation cup since younger
players are facing the older generation
uh mostly the younger players have um uh
went into the The Knockout phase of the
tournament uh the the the older uh
gentleman did not qualify uh but what
you're gonna do here we have a two
spectacular young players pregnant and
Vincent kaimer and we are going to show
game four of their match uh game one
ended by Vincent taking the lead I will
just show you a part of the game where
Vincent had the white pieces um and
maybe this would be okay let's say this
is the position and Vincent pushed H5
here and now it's a it's a very short
combination uh g-captors and H5 G
captures and H5 and now proc has to be
very very careful as Prague is playing
um uh the black pieces in this game he
has to play Rook B8 for example and uh
or let's say try and trade off this Rook
or maybe he should have done it even
before that but here proc plays The Rook
a captures uh Rook one captures on A3
and now uh he just gives Vincent the
attack captors captures H6 sorry about
that uh and there is no going back from
this now as uh well the uh the the the
all of the pieces attacking the black
king are just too powerful the game
followed with Rook captures on C3 uh
Vincent um uh or rather prog attack the
Vincent's Queen and uh Vincent just
played H7 check King h8 and now if there
was no F7 Pawn Knight the G6 would be
Checkmate so of course uh just Knight
captures on F7 and there is no good uh
continuation here you can give up the
queen uh which is uh not all that great
knight captures with check Knight
captures Queen captures and C3 so that
obviously doesn't work so uh after this
Knight captures an F7 check we have
Knight captures on F7 but now of course
9 night the G6 is Checkmate so that's
how Vincent took the lead in the second
game Prague had the white pieces and he
tried the nice D4 it was a nice Queen
Gambit game uh but Vincent uh very very
uh you know easily equalized and there
wasn't all that much in that game Prague
tried to push for the win he did have a
two to one advantage it was a rook end
game he was he had two points Vincent
had one but he showed that he can vary
easily hold this uh game three ended in
a draw as well and this is now game for
the one where Prague has to win on
demand if he wants the force tie break
so let's see what happened uh Prague had
the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 he now goes for that at the
opening with D5 by Vincent D5 by Vincent
and now G3 going for the king's Indian
attack C5 with Bishop to G2 and knights
to F6 so uh well played in a very
principal matter if white does not push
pawns if white wants to control center
with his pieces of course you will take
advantage of that and claim the center
with your Pawn so here we have castles
E6 and now Pawn to C4 and now Knight the
C6 is
um more common here but the Vincent uh
continues with Pawn to D4 we have E3
challenging the central structure Knight
to C6 and E captures on d4c captures D3
and Bishop to C5 nicely continuing
development Bishop to G5 by Prague and
the H6 forcing proc to decide what to do
with the bishop do you go back or do you
capture an F6 cap factoring on F6 is the
way to go Queen captures or rather G
captures as was played in the game and
now there is one game in the database
between Dmitry akumenko and Pavel eliano
from the video World Cup 2015 in Baku
Azerbaijan where Knight
beta D2 was played but here we have
Knight to A3 by Prague and it is now as
of move 11 that we have a completely new
game so the idea is that okay of course
black can capture black can mess up your
Pawn structure here but if Vincent does
this then he gave up the bishop pair and
let's say after Castle Sprague will put
a rook on B1 and it's a very very nice
position you have the semi-open file for
your Rook if B6 then the bishop truly
comes alive so yeah you don't really
care about your double date Pawn uh so
okay of course if instant knows this uh
he just castles the safety and even
though the king side is ruined a bit
Prague does not have a dark Square
Bishop he already fianchetted his light
Square Bishop so there is no good way to
uh to actually create something here
okay the Knight can move the queen can
get the H5 but more than that you really
don't have so here Rook to B1 now of
course uh B4 is the idea at some point
we have King G7 by Vincent adding more
protection to the pawns here and queen
to D2 now we have Queen to D6 and now
Knight the C2 now getting ready to push
that B Pawn so of course Pawn to A5 and
now after A3 again preparing B4 Vincent
just stops this with Pawn to A4 now B4
of course we'll be met with a capture
some B3 Alpha song so here Queen to E2
and now uh Pawn to F5 we have knighted
the D2 again uh adding more uh Firepower
to this B3 square and preparing B4 if
you don't push B4 uh you're just gonna
be struggling uh for the rest of the
game so best of the D7 and pawn to B4
finally eight characters on B3 Alpha
Knight captures on B3 now attacking the
bishop and Vincent just plays
um uh upon onto B6 you could also
capture an A3 but that will weaken your
D4 Pawn a bit too much so here just a
nice B6 of instant just needs a draw
here to beat Prague in the match and
proceed to the semifinals Knight
captures on c5b captures and now Rook to
B5 now Prague wants to double up on the
B file and he does have the past a pawn
the Knight is defending it so if you can
trade off everything then maybe you can
push that a pawn to Victory but Vincent
has a very very strong Center and of
course he will start pushing pawns Pawn
to E5 and now it's a question whether or
not Vincent can uh prepare eee for if he
can it's gonna be very hard for proc to
defend this so Rook after B1
uh he for the moment he has sufficient
control over the E4 square and The Rook
8 to B8 now Vincent wants to trade off
all of the Rooks of the board we have
Knight the E1 uh preparing Knight to F3
and now Rook F to E8 again at some point
uh ee4 would be very nice so Queen to C2
getting the queen away from the e file
but also still keeping an eye on that E4
square and now Knight to A7 a very nice
move by Vincent as it forces proc to
trade off the Rooks so Rook captures
Rook captures and Rook captures on B8 we
have Queen captures and Knight to F3 so
okay Vincent still with a very strong
Center his King is a bit weak so if
Prague can somehow get that Queen to H5
maybe Knight to H4 to F5 maybe the
bishop can come into the game uh you
know attacks might happen but he has to
play very very uh precise move so
Knights the C8 by Vincent he wants to
play Knight D6 maybe put more pressure
on that E4 square and the H3 now we have
Pawn to F6 adding more uh protection to
D5 now the queen might also be activated
as if the Queen ever wants to reach H5
you're gonna have to play some like
Queen to D1 Queen T2 and then the black
queen will have access to uh to some
nice squares along the B file so here
are Knights the H4 uh clearing the path
for the White Queen Queenie two queen H5
Queen to G6 that would be the dream and
Knight to D6 now we have Bishop to D5 by
Prague and now we have Queen to B6 by
Vincent Queen to D1 and now Queen to B2
like we mentioned if the Queen ever
moves the black queen will gain some
squares Here and Now Prague plays Pawn
to A4 and this is definitely the correct
way to go uh you really want to start
pushing that pass Pawn if you just rush
it with Queen to H5 Vincent's idea was
of course Queen C1 check and once the
king moves Queen G5 and you're you're
offering the queen trade you're
defending the G6 Square so nothing
really happening here in the night here
nicely covers F7 so even Queen to F7 is
not possible so A beautiful setup here
by Vincent so of course proc plays A4
this is the absolute best move and now
Vincent says all right no more waiting I
have to strike in the center Pawn to E4
and now uh how do you continue uh well
proc decided to go Queen to H5 of course
it makes sense you are preparing Queen
G6 so now Queen to C1 check has to be
played if Vincent doesn't go for this
maneuver it's game over Queen to G2 and
queen to G5 forcing a queen trade and
now uh not forcing offering your queen
trade but Queen back to D1 here Vincent
has to continue the attack he plays F4
and now Prague is still better but he
has to continue pushing the pass Pawn
but it's very hard I mean look at this
beautiful Center look at the queen look
at the bishop here the Knight ready to
jump into the game it you know it takes
uh uh you know a very very cool cool
headed moment uh just to push that pawn
on A5 and he it would be good for Prague
but here he played the D captures on e4
and now he allows Vincent
um well uh make the attack happen a
little bit faster as the pawn is an A4
instead of A5 so F captures on G3 F
captures on G3 and now Queen to E3
now if let's say D3 D2 can be played uh
Vincent's Pawn is also very very close
to promotion and now how can Prague play
this well uh here he played Queen to C2
and this is this simply will not to do
here what you have to play is Queen to
H5 if you are ever to achieve more than
a draw here point is the now after let's
say queen D2 check King moves and queen
to G5 uh that would be that would be
very good for Prague because now after
Queen G5 you have Knight to F5 check any
Bishop captures an F5 you can trade
let's say if captures e captures on F5
and after Knight captures your Pawn can
now go to A5 it would be better if the
pawn was already on A5 so now it will go
to A6 but uh you know let's say Knights
the D6 A6 and now Knights the C8 the
guards the A7 Square it's hard to say if
if you will be able to to win this so
what you could do after Queen to H5 and
queen to D to check King to H1 is maybe
you don't go Queen to G5 also possible
is just to continue checking Queen to C1
check and I say okay how are you
escaping Perpetual King to H2 Queen the
C2 check okay you have to play Knight to
G2 if you are to escape the Perpetual
but now uh Bishop the E8 can be played
for example and after let's say queen G4
check Bishop to G6 you can now play E5
here very nice move opening up some some
files in front of the black king also
the queen has access to D7 check this
would put pressure on the Knight so it's
hard to it's hard to say for example F
characters now you push A5 and who is
faster D3 A6 D2 now you're gonna play
Queen E6 threat and queen to G8 to check
now if D1 Queen you will uh uh win the
game the black king will not Escape all
the checks but Knight F7 stops this and
now let's say A7 D1 Queen and A8 Queen
there are now Four Queens on the board
so it was uh you know there was a
possibility for this happening but it's
uh you know quite um quite a wild game
it's hard to say and Prague of course is
better but with Four Queens on the board
who's to say what would happen however
Pratt played Queen to C2 and now Vincent
completely takes over the game because
now D3 comes with Tempo and the black's
position is just Unstoppable proc played
Queen to F2 but now the spectacular
Bishop captures on H3 of course the
bishop cannot be captured as Queen
captures and F2 is happening King to G1
and now Queen to C1 with check forcing
the king to come to H2 and now after
King to H2 there is only one game one
move that wins the game for Vincent but
even a draw is fine however feel free to
pause the video here and to win the game
for Vincent while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
Unstoppable idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen to C2 that's the good stuff so
congratulations to everyone who found
this there is no uh escaping now uh as
uh well you're threatening to win the
queen and once let's say King to G2 is
played which was played in the game
Vincent just played D2 and he was in
this position on move 42 that uh
pragnananda resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
whatever you do D1 uh brings another
queen into the game and there's just
nothing you can do the F5 square is
covered too many times there's no way
for the queen to reach G6 in time as D1
comes with checks so I mean there's no
playing this and even if you if you play
King captures an H3 Queen captures and
F2 of course the queen is hanging uh
there's absolutely nothing you can do so
after D2 uh Vincent wins and Prague is
now out of the Julius bear generation
cup and what does this mean for the
pairings well let's check it out these
are the knockout brackets
as presented on on Twitter by by the
meltwater Champions Chester you can see
that Magnus eliminated Levon uh so uh
and the Vincent eliminated pregnant
industrial magnets will be facing
Vincent kymer in the semi-finals which
is of course very exciting uh Hans
Neiman lost to Liam who won the first
game then Hans retaliated in the second
game third game ended in a drawing
fourth game was won by Le so very nicely
done and uh the the battle between Arjun
irrigation and Christopher you was truly
an epic one it had to go into tie breaks
and in the end Arjun was standing
Victorious but it was it was an
incredible battle so Magnus versus
Vincent and Liam Li versus Arjun
irrigation will be the semi-finals and
we'll see who emerges Victorious and
ends up in the finals but one thing we
don't have to worry about is Magnus
facing hunts in the finals so we
definitely know that the final match
will happen
uh so yeah uh that's the game and the
match hope you guys enjoyed that very
nicely played by both of them Prague
played some incredible chess in this
event but Vincent as the newest member
of the 2700 club uh shows uh once again
why he is the newest member of the 2700
Club so very well deserved uh I would
like to thank uh pass interior Stuart
Matthew is there a king Brian parking
and golden Pawn for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Holy
Spirit generation cup Knockouts until it
finishes uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day